Gabrielle you really have been a mother
to your children now and now starting on
the journey all over again with your
youngest oldest child what is that
[Laughter]
oh my gosh you know it's it's it's not
dissimilar in the sense that like I was
like oh my gosh a girl a girl finally
girl girl girl and I that I get to like
shape and and and
she came out exactly who she is and no
matter you know who I wanted her to be
she is exactly who she's supposed to be
and I wanted sporty spies she's like I'm
Gonna Give You Posh Baby like literally
all the other spices but sporty um she's
taught me that
you can have all the wants and dreams
for your children but they are who they
are and it is your job to love them and
guide them and and try to give them the
world uh but you're not in control you
know what I mean like I want to make
sure she has like good manners she's
kind she's compassionate she's she's a
student of the world that she's got a
world perspective not a town perspective
but if she gonna be Shady she's gonna be
Shady you know what I mean if she wants
to wear full accessories to tennis it's
gonna happen
um like she walked into dance class and
she said
the kids aren't serious
she's three
they can barely go to the bathroom this
is who she is
who she is
still a child of this world and we try
to create a loving safe bubble in our
home in our school Community with our
extended family but she's still a queer
person in this country in this world and
she has to fight every day to be seen to
be loved uh to be nurtured to be thought
of as worthy and it's a fight every day
for her for her and for us it is a
struggle and she is not completely
unlike Elegance in the sense of the
yearning for loved ones to see them and
love them completely and without
condition
are you in trouble
minding my birth certificate
I need you to help me I want to be a
Marine
Marine
no you ain't scarier than two left shoes
and everybody can see it
when wounded or injured in this attack
including several American servicemen
who were on patrol there this all I have
left
of the dream I held for you Elegance I
want to know
what made you go into this place where
it was a dangerous place it was a place
where people wanted to harm you yet you
thrived and you survived what what in
your mind made you say that I could do
this there is nothing more dangerous and
demoralizing to being homeless in
America
and I needed a complete 180 from where I
was at that point in my life my mother
always said if you're going to wear a
label we're the best ones in the U.S
Marines it's the best label in the
military so that's why I did it
Gabrielle I got to ask you uh through
this process because like you just
mentioned your mother you lost your
mother enduring this process what was
that response what did that add to the
fact that he was sending you items from
his mother you you were you know you
were staring at the man who lived this
life with this woman what kind of
pressure what was that like with
responsibility
well as as a mother
I just want to be a part of healing for
a child
um I wanted to to be there as a mother
uh except that wasn't my job and it was
kind of difficult to separate
me as a mother me as a producer and me
as Talent me as an actor
um because I I just wanted to hold him I
just wanted to make everything okay as
as most mothers want
but I had a job to do and
I had to stay focused on the task at
hand and it it there were times it felt
cruel
um
that is that is the truth of the story
and I had to it was our job to tell the
truth
um but I also needed to find her
compassion
and find the the common ground that that
we share and I I you know I I used to be
a judger of my characters and I would
act out that judgment on screen and here
I didn't want to do that I needed to
know
that there is a some kind of common
ground that we could find and that
common ground is the fact that we've
both been willing to sacrifice
things that are very important to us
whether that be our children whether
that be our scruples
and at times in my life my soul
for opportunity for money for a
relationship for access
to be seen to be chosen we will all
barter with something
um and just because bartering with my
children was not my Ministry I still
found but was able to find that Common
Ground Jeremy
to take on this role but then you have
as an antagonist one of the Great ACT I
mean I think one of the greatest black
actors there has ever been in a book in
Woodbine and what were those scenes like
where y'all had to go face to face and
toe to toe and you still brought an
Elegance to that yeah I mean Bo is he's
really special and
um he's nothing but love
um and he likes to cut up so
um it was a great experience working
with him and and and being able to
create this narrative together because
ultimately with this film we know that
it speaks outside of just us and we hope
that it resonates with someone out there
who needs who needs this tangible
representation to see themselves and to
know that it's going to be okay so it
was such a gift to be able to step into
elegance's story and carry some of that
um you know his his kind of pain and her
and and also my own I think we healed
each other all of us we found healing on
the other side of this film and that's
just one of the greatest gifts Elegance
your mom's not here but do you did you
think about her throughout filming and
now when you watch this movie
what do you think she's saying to you
huh well um ever since she's passed I've
been fortunate enough to have good
people in my life including these two
right here who remind me that although
your ancestors may not do for you in
their life what they're supposed to they
can work on the other side and I think
she's working I'm on Entertainment
Tonight right now I'm talking to you
I've only seen you on YouTube uh so you
know it's working out
um you know ultimately I have a deep
gratitude to Gabrielle for giving me an
opportunity to find closure with my mom
and my mother is the first person to
ever love me fully she's also the first
person to ever fully reject me so
it's funny when she passed
we hadn't spoken for like maybe 18 years
something like that and I thought she
was completely had moved on and you know
when she when I went to her house to you
know clean it out for her she had all of
my articles she had
um on her computer the tabs were open to
things that I had done with my short
films in the past so you know I I feel
like she's proud of me oh she's proud of
you the movie is fantastic thank you
Jeremy what do you think this will mean
there's someone out there that is
struggling with this what do you think
I think what it means is
you know you the message for me is you
are more than enough you have always
been more than enough there is love and
the respect on the other side there is a
community of people who are waiting to
accept you and protect you Elegance
talks about making this film about
protecting the man to your left and to
your right
um so for anyone experiencing rejection
or feeling like there is no Worth to
their life or to their existence I want
you to know that that is a lie
just a lie and it's not true and I feel
very fortunate that through my life and
through my artistic Journey I've been
able to find people that championing me
for who I am so I'm just grateful to be
a vessel to be able to continue to do
that
[Music]